6 23 it's Tuesday Morning the second
annual tag Global Spirit awards are
coming up later this month right here in
the valley yeah this is exciting and to
Mark the occasion we are joined by the
awards co-founder Master mixologist I
mean you're like a guru of cocktails
Tony abuganum also the modern mixologist
and we are so excited to have you here
today first let's talk about this big
event that's going on that people can
take part in absolutely Heather thank
you it's the second annual we kick off
on Sunday January 29th with the cocktail
competition featuring six MGM properties
sponsored by Woody Creek it's called the
Lion's Den all right oh it's gonna be
held at the old Bank nightclub inside
Bellagio it's open to everyone please
come out and cheer on your favorite then
we go to Monday Monday we do our
educational track over at the Delano
Monday night at Cleaver
we have a dinner then dinner is Tuesday
and Wednesday and then it all ends on
Friday with the pink Thai Gala up at
Skyfall and just to give people an idea
of you know this is isn't just a bunch
of people getting around to just drink a
bunch of awesome uh that's fantastic too
but what is the sort of goal of an event
like this well really at the foundation
is a spirit's competition so you enter
your Brands they're judged by a panel of
global judges from four continents to
get best of show which we have a best of
show winner from last
year's Reposado tequila it was best to
show in the reposado category and when I
thought we'd do today yeah some fun have
a little our own competition yes don't
you think John are you ready I'm ready
for it if this goes as well as the
cooking competition I'm in good shape
Tony what are we making all right we're
gonna make Palomas this is a drink we
feature at libertine social we're going
to start off by squeezing half a lime
right into the glass we're going to
build this ala Manute okay the drink I
discovered in Guadalajara in 1999. I
brought it back to Las Vegas to the
Bellagio and like I said featured drink
at libertine social inside Mandalay Bay
okay all right now a pinch of that sea
salt goes right into the glass John if
you want to grab grab that Reposado and
we can start working no I think I'm
going to keep it here
just drizzle in about two ounces two
ounces yeah okay now I've never been the
best with measuring well that's okay I
mean does that make them strong if you
like a real Paloma that looks good so
Tony I actually studied abroad in
Guadalajara a little bit after that and
so I became a big fan of the Paloma but
what I noticed is it always tastes
better in Mexico well that's because of
the Mexican squirt it's sweetened with
pure cane sugar and not high fructose
corn syrup like it is in the United
States so it's good here but it's even
better we've got about a minute left
what else we gotta do we're gonna go
ahead and top that with the Mexican
squirt okay so we'll just go ahead and
fill that up you have a modern
mixologist 24 degree bar spoon I think
mine actually I'm you know don't judge
me Tony you're in it for the win Heather
right so I go this way well generally
it's the other way but uh
it goes in as the garnish oh okay all
right and just the way they drink them
in Guadalajara right here I'm not
waiting for him cheers Breakfast of
Champions here uh Tony thanks for coming
this morning good job tag Spirit Awards
and you've got yourself a little whiskey
right there so we're getting going here
all right Tony we're gonna put all this
information folks on the website so that
you can go out you can enjoy some good
drinks and say hi to Tony yeah I love it
all right thank you very much welcome to
Las Vegas after this